mariana exprimió tres limones para hacer
limonada ella exprimió 42 mil litros de
jugo del primer limón ok nos dice
también que exprimió 36.000 y litros de
jugo del segundo limón y 45 mililitros
del tercer limón la pregunta que nos
hacen es cuánto jugo exprimió marianas
de los tres limones y este es un
problema muy pero muy sencillo verdad lo
único que tenemos que hacer es sumar las
tres cantidades de jugo de limón que
exprimió en cada uno de los casos verdad
entonces en el primer limón exprimió 42
mililitros y recordemos que a veces se
pone mililitros con el de mayúscula oa
veces se usa con l minúscula
o incluso todavía hay gente que usa una
l
digamos cursiva en este vídeo vamos a
hacerlo con mayúscula muy bien tenemos
42 mililitros también tenemos que en el
segundo caso exprimió
y 6 mililitros y en el tercer caso
exprimió 45 mililitros muy bien entonces
lo único que tenemos que hacer ahora es
sumar estas cantidades y nos va a quedar
en términos de mililitros verdad estamos
sumando mililitros entonces si sumamos
todo esto empecemos por ejemplo con las
unidades tenemos 2 más 6 son 88 más 5
son 13 verdad que es igual a tres
unidades y una decena muy bien vamos a
sumar las decenas uno más cuatro son 55
más tres son ocho y ocho y cuatro son
doce decenas que es lo mismo que 120
unidades verdad entonces ya tenemos la
respuesta a este primer problema fueron
123 mililitros de jugo de limón los que
exprimió marianas vamos con otro
problema vamos a ver este problema que
tenemos aquí dice
sara virtió 5 latas 5 latas de aceite de
motor en el contenedor que tenemos abajo
muy bien entonces aquí está nuestro
contenedor verdad y al parecer después
de haber convertido todo el aceite de
esas 5 latas llegamos hasta esta altura
que si no me equivoco son justamente a
la mitad entre 40 y 50 mililitros y esos
son 45 mililitros muy bien dice todas
las latas contienen la misma cantidad de
aceite muy bien y ahora la pregunta que
nos hacen es cuántos mililitros de
aceite de motor había en cada lata muy
bien entonces nosotros digamos teníamos
cinco latas ahí está la primera lata con
su aceite la segunda lata también que
tenía aceite y bueno por ahorita
imaginen que las estoy haciendo todas
iguales verdad por qué
se supone que todas contienen la misma
cantidad de aceite muy bien ahí tenemos
ahora nuestra cuarta lata y finalmente
esta que es la quinta lata con la misma
cantidad de aceite el detalle es que
nosotros no sabemos cuánto aceite tiene
cada una de estas latas verdad pero lo
que sí sabemos es que tenemos cinco de
ellas verdad tenemos cinco latas y no
sabemos cuánto tiene de cuánto cuánto
aceite tiene cada una de ellas pero lo
que sí sabemos es que al multiplicar las
vamos a tener un total de 45 mililitros
cierto entonces la pregunta que tenemos
que hacernos es si yo multiplico a 5 por
este número o cual número tendría que
ser para que me dé 45 y esa es una
respuesta muy fácil verdad porque 9 por
5 o 5 por 9 es 45 entonces cada uno
de estas latas tenía 9 mililitros de
aceite 9 mililitros de aceite muy bien
cada una de esas latas contenía una
cantidad exacta de 9 mililitros